[Music]
relatively soon a hotel Tower and the
strip will be saying bonjour to the
Paris Resort Caesars Entertainment
announcing one of the newly rebranded
horseshoe Towers will be Marie branded
again eight news now reporter Ryan
Matthey joining us from the pool deck of
the Paris with details on the project
well back in April County Commissioners
approved saying narvoir to that building
right there it's currently the Jubilee
Tower over at the Horseshoe soon to be
the Versailles Tower of the Paris Resort
from Bally's to Horseshoe to Paris it
only made sense Caesar's entertainment
announced the 100 million dollar project
on Monday an expansion of the Paris
Resort taking part of the horseshoe with
it on the inside over 700 rooms are
getting a makeover and balconies if they
face the West on the outside a new roof
will add roughly 17 feet to the top and
eventually a pedestrian walkway will
connect the two senior vice president
for both properties Jason gregorick
horseshoe really belonged on center
strip now as far as what the hotel you
know we took this Tower because the way
it's situated and also the great
response we get for the Paris brand
we're going to create a very new and
modern fun Parisian theme it comes just
after a Rebrand of the Bally's Resort to
the Horseshoe but the last time this
Tower saw a remodel on the inside was
2014 and now the new construction will
come as the Boulevard in front of it
gets repaved for November's F1 there's a
well thought out plan on how the traffic
will will be I guess interrupted but uh
you know it's it's part of Las Vegas
it's the growing pains and we feel good
about it and with an end date months
away tourists and workers on the Strip
are conflicted on the new edition I
think it's unnecessary yeah because I'd
rather see a new building for 100
million like this new hotel like a new
thing new uh this area if it's going to
make them money and they want to do it
it's fine they bought it out I mean as
long as it looks good